we we'd also you know we need to
remember that Christ is the perfect
example of all of this right
right so his ministry was three years
long but his whole life you know as a
carpenter
um was he like carving crosses and
giving them to people you know probably
not that would have been a weird time
but you know his his whole reality would
have been offered up to the father as a
prayer and he and because he's Christ he
does everything perfectly which means
it's perfectly humble right so when
people come to me and they say yeah I'm
thinking about doing this thing or
whatever I'm like great do it and do it
as well as you possibly can because when
you do that they get well be prideful
about it no you will if it's actually
done well it'll be done in the image of
Christ and it'll be perfectly humble
it'll be a great offering
um and that's you know like Father Chris
said I don't think there's necessarily
it's not a problem like Christ doesn't
call us to be Bankers or artists or
lawyers or Housewives he calls bankers
and artists and lawyers and Housewives
to be disciples that's what he calls
um so whatever you do do it as well as
you possibly can it'll be a good icon
um and if it's bad art it probably stems
from Bad theology get your theology
corrected
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so hello everybody I am very pleased to
be here with Father Christopher Father
James and Father David also known as the
band luxury some of you might have
followed their stories some of you might
not know but they started a band a long
time ago when they were young a rock
band and uh many events in their lives
brought them ultimately to not all of
the people in the band but three who are
here with us today to convert Orthodoxy
and ultimately to become priests and
there's a documentary about that called
parallel love which is a wonderful
documentary I recommend it to to anyone
which kind of traces the story so we're
going to look into to a little bit what
their story is you know the different uh
they put out an album a few years ago as
well they even did some live shows this
summer which you hadn't done in a while
and also their future projects and we'll
also talk about what it means to be an
Orthodox Christian who is also involved
in secular art and so
fathers thank you for uh thank you for
coming to talk to me
thank you for having us
and so I'm hoping one of you can maybe
just tell our audience this just the
basic story of how it is that I'm
talking to three rock rock and roll
priests here
it's father Chris's job yeah Chris's job
I knew I was going to be conscripted
well uh the three of us you know
actually met in college uh back in the
early 90s uh when all of us were very
kind of interested in music and playing
music we met at this Conservative
Christian College desperate to find
like-minded musicians uh and we wound up
starting a band together
um
played around uh kind of the Atlanta
Athens Southeastern scene uh for a
number of years uh eventually we got
signed to tooth and nail records uh
after playing a festival up in Illinois
but around that same time uh at least
Father David and I uh were also
studying church history with a with a
group of friends uh that led us
eventually into discovering uh the
Eastern Orthodox faith we wound up
converting much to Father James uh
Chagrin at the time uh but eventually uh
Father James and his wife became
Orthodox as well but you know the band
continued uh during that time uh you
know we were touring and playing quite a
bit
um and then as we started getting older
and having children uh the the live
aspect of the band uh waned uh I
eventually went off to Seminary uh to
pursue the priesthood and then a number
of years later Father James father David
did as well
uh and then uh got a phone call from
Father David about 2013.
saying hey man I'm writing some more
songs you guys want to go in the studio
uh so we did
uh and then around the same time a
friend of ours Matt who's also in the
band but was a filmmaker
I just thought it would be really
interesting to do a story and a
documentary on
you know the story of the band uh the
fact that three of us became Orthodox
priests this is the the first album and
writing and recording since being priest
and
um the the documentary has done very
well much to our surprise we thought
maybe two or three people would be
interested in it but uh NPR and other
places uh were very interested so it's
been a interesting last
few years uh as priests trying to
navigate
being priests but also
playing rock and roll
so you played some live concerts this
summer how was that
do you wear your cat socks no no no
no Father James maybe you talk about
that experience yeah so it was last
summer we played um
I don't know what to say about it I mean
we hadn't played in ages uh and I guess
the idea had come up that maybe we could
try to do some shows and wanting to
promote the record a little bit even the
record record stretched out trophies
stretched out for ages before we
actually got it released
um and I'm not I can't remember how it
all kind of came about but we ended up
um being asked to play at a festival in
Alabama furnace Fest which is primarily
like hardcore punk rock metal
kind of thing and we got asked to play
which was funny and but it was beautiful
did they reach out to you yeah oh yeah
um I think so is that correct I think so
I think I think they came to us first we
weren't looking to play
and in the process of doing that we
thought well we probably ought to play
another show before that to sort of warm
up to that
and ended up playing a show and at the
Earl in Atlanta which is kind of a cool
club we hadn't played there in many
years
um so we ended up playing in two shows
which was crazy so we you know we had
these rehearsals and
I don't I I was pretty nervous about
actually getting on stage again but it
ended up being I mean it ended up being
a lot of fun it was it was enjoyable
it's you know it's a diversion but um
but we ended up doing that last year and
um
I mean I don't not the not the then
prove we couldn't do it anymore we
proved that we still could do something
but uh we did it and there it is it's on
video in places so oh it is can you find
that video we could find it no no we
can't find the video it's well hidden
okay all right I would have liked it I
would have liked to see that and Father
David since you're singing how was that
for you in terms of a concert because
that different energy
yeah it was very different
um
you know again like Father Chris said we
have we hadn't played together live in
that in that setting for almost 20 years
and so
um it was a very different energy now
being a priest and sort of what I felt
comfortable doing what I didn't feel I
felt very much self-conscious the whole
time
um which I I didn't feel that earlier
you know early on and so it might have
been a lot of it might have been just
around singing live which is a difficult
thing to do and trying to be energetic
and all that but not so much the priests
stuff I didn't that wasn't the
uncomfortable part
um it was more of just
not having done this in so long so yeah
and also I imagine being older and just
being more aware of certain things in
terms of
yeah you still want to be like exciting
and interesting and provocative and all
that and there is somewhere in the back
your head the idea of priesthood
your congregation and all of that who
weren't there thank god
um because that would be even stranger
you know because it's a different
reality but no I mean it's just you know
you get older and you want to you want
to want to be a pro age appropriate that
kind of thing
um
it was uh it was odd you know and how
what age were the people in the audience
that's probably was it was it a bunch of
20 year olds like there's a bunch of
teenagers or was it more kind of adults
definitely it was more people are I mean
we're all over 50 now and so yeah it was
definitely more of our
dead Rock Crown
but it was it was loud he played hard
and heavy and loud and it was great you
know uh I don't really want to do it
again but yeah it was a good experience
I mean I think that that's interesting
if you're saying you don't you don't
want what why don't you want to do it
again
it doesn't do anything for me in
particular at this point
like my my own interest is in
songwriting and making records that kind
of thing that's where my I get the most
joy and interest out of that the playing
live thing I suppose if we did it more
often I would I would feel I could make
get my way into it a little bit more but
it's not uh I don't have I don't really
have any interest in that so but I don't
even go to shows anymore so you know I
just don't have a lot of experience you
know interest in that kind of thing so
but it's still an interesting in the the
music part like it's not it's not
disillusioned with the music it's just
the live thing is not the right
yeah I mean the whole The Arc of making
music and putting out music and then the
live part of that like my interest ends
once the record when I'm holding it in
my hand that's where that's where I
finished my job and anything beyond that
I don't have any interest in at all so
so Father James father Christopher what
about you in terms of the live
experience did you have a similar
experience
I had a lot more fun than I thought I
would I have the same kind of hesitation
you know you're a priest you know
but like a lot of things you know some
priests they go out and they play golf I
guess or they um I don't know what's
something analogous they go fishing or
hiking or people who watch you though
people don't watch you yeah well yeah
yeah this is this is different but it's
like
I don't know I mean that I enjoyed it a
lot but I'm with my brother I'm kind of
I it's that's
uh you know it's fine I mean it's it's I
like to get together with the band I
enjoy that part and if people want to
watch us getting together I mean we have
a lot of fun we tell jokes and we sit
around they could just we could do that
we could just have a rehearsal they
could just all watch us sitting there
eating a meal and then making jokes and
playing for five minutes and then
correcting you know that if that we
could do that that would be more fun but
um maybe that's a concept maybe we could
a terrible idea
when it's time has come I don't know
well back to you by the Christopher yeah
I mean I I enjoyed it and um you know
I'm open to doing it again but it was
certainly
uh there was tension I mean just
how do we do this like you know we we're
performing in front of people and it's
it's
but we're we're priests and we're not I
don't know it just
you know the tension of all of that I I
think at some point I I just said okay
well I guess just embrace the tension of
it and um
you know just kind of remember who we
are
um so you know I'm not opposed to doing
it again but you know it just I realized
kind of what Father David said I mean it
didn't really do anything for me in
terms of like oh we got to do this more
often it was just it was fun it just
felt like kind of uh Nostalgia
especially the show in Atlanta being
able to see a bunch of friends of ours
that's where we used to play all of the
time so it just felt like a reunion of
sorts and so many of our extended
plan down there you know many of them
have also become Orthodox over the years
so that was just pretty neat to see some
of them and
yeah
so I this is something I mean we've had
conversations before I think all maybe I
don't know if I've had this conversation
with all three of you for sure two of
you for sure and Father David so even in
the things you're saying I feel a little
a need like there's an uneasiness in the
way that you express your relationship
to to to the music now to the concert uh
I don't know if it's uneasiness or at
least a sense in which you're not sure
how to place your feet maybe that's the
best way to understand like how do I
position myself
um and so I know that there's a lot of
people watching this uh a lot of people
who are in the the secular art World
um you know people who do animation
video games that watch my content you
know people who reach out to me and a
lot and many people feel that that
uneasiness you could say not sure how it
is do I live these these two lives and
so I I was wondering if you
if it's something that you're let's say
exploring
on your own do you see a connection is
there a connection between
your Orthodox faith and the music or do
you feel like it really is just two
lines running next to each other
well I mean I I thought I think a lot
about that I I think our our
the bands sort of prime uh Prime
experience was pre-internet days so
there was a there was an aspect of it
where that was very segmented like this
was what you do you can get up on stage
nobody really knows anything about you
there's not it's a it's a Persona that
you can you sort of adopt and there's a
kind of comfort in that where you can
just simply you can be that thing in
that setting and there's no you know
nobody's taking cell phone videos of
your playing you know there's nothing
that's suddenly this becomes a permanent
sort of reality right and you can kind
of create that and take some sort of
comfort in creating that Persona and
entering into it nowadays you know it's
they all they know who you are they know
your wives names I know they've seen
pictures of your kids they see your
Facebook page your Instagram and all
these different things like it's
suddenly it's all just jammed together
and that's I think where the discomfort
comes is
um how you know am I priest when I'm
playing music well people know you're a
priest because they've seen your stuff
right or am I a musician when I'm a
priest that's the other you know we feel
the same sort of tension in church you
know so I think we live in an age which
is way too Overexposed with all of our
our realities right
um and so my own discomfort
um is about you know how much do I want
people to know about me you know
um and the reason I don't have a you
know sort of YouTube no offense a
YouTube channel these different things
like I I just don't want that much sort
of exposure I don't I want to be
somewhat mysterious still
right um so that I can keep some for me
personally I can keep some bifurcated
realities in my life I think a little
bit I don't that make sense or not but
this is a different age we live in and
your your musicians nowadays sort of I
think they have to have everything out
there all the time for everybody and I
think that's a
yeah I I think the flip side of that I
mean we've talked a lot about this kind
of amongst the band and I mean Father
David you always make that point that
you know
parallel lines don't intersect and so
this idea of
but you know I think there is the sense
that we have always struggled as a band
you know trying to understand how does
our Christian faith kind of inform our
arts and and vice versa and
you know we never set out to be a
Christian band or you know have this
agenda to win souls or whatever we were
just
you know trying to create art but you
know I think and I mentioned this in in
the movie this idea like Father
Alexander schmerman talks a little bit
about in his book for the life of the
world about this vocation
of being a priest of creation who takes
the matter of this world and offers it
up to God with Thanksgiving and praise
and then it gets returned to us as
something life-giving I know for me in
my journey into Orthodoxy whilst being
in a band at the same time that was so
helpful for me I think to just think of
art that way
you know that we're somehow offering up
the matter just like Bread and Wine
eucharistically we're offering up the
matter of our talents and hopefully God
blesses it and we can create something
beautiful and you know it reflects our
our life and our world of you
um so I think that's been helpful I
think for us as a band to think about it
that way
also
so I mean I would say about that though
like we wouldn't do this in the church
like right yeah well that's the I think
that that's really where in some ways it
becomes fascinating for me or to think
about because
and and I think that's probably why
people are so fascinated by your story
as well because if you were Protestant
pastors you could probably do it in the
church right it would be you would be
using it as worship music or whatever
you could you could do that and you
could get away with it right you could
have the concert in the church and get
away with it but in for sure everybody
knows that you couldn't do this in
church like you couldn't use it it's not
a lit it's not a strictly liturgical
action in the in the strict sense uh
but at the same time as as music
right but at the same time like in the
words of Father Alexander schmerman that
you mentioned and I think just in
general in terms of say maximus and the
way that we understand
Christ's presence in the world we have a
sense in which liturgical the form of
the Liturgy or what the Liturgy does can
be applied at smaller levels right I
often talk about how a family meal is
somewhat liturgical it's not strictly
liturgical but it's somewhat liturgical
because it's Binding Together around a
common a common thing you know there's a
type of dance that happens in a in a
family meal that is ritualized and I
think there's the same thing with the
concert but I I'm trying to I'm I'm
trying to see father Christopher like
what is it that it it's expressing right
the the let's say
what positive thing even if we think in
terms of of uh of Orthodox
mindset what positive thing does rock
and roll manifest like what could it
manifest as positive
and this is like a really like this is
this is not I'm this is not a trick
question it's not a I'm really trying to
I'm I myself am trying to kind of see
this I have kind of an idea but I'd like
to hear your thought about it
yeah I mean I'll say a few things but
you guys can jump in as well I I just
know when I first heard your talk on the
the Pentecost for the zombie apocalypse
and you you talked about this idea of
kind of like a a narthex art or kind of
I can't remember how you term it but
it's kind of like it's not quite in the
church but it's somehow
reflecting something of reality it's
entering into even kind of the depths of
The Human Experience
um and I mean I'm a bass player so I
mean my bass player my my bass parts are
entering but when I think of you know
like Father David and his themes you
know in his lyrics I mean I think
there's a there's definitely a depth
there maybe in the same way that like
folk music is an Eastern European
countries like these aren't songs that
we would hear in the Liturgy but they're
definitely
you know reflecting on a lived
experience
um for those producing it
hmm
I want to hear someone else's ideas on
this I know Father David it's something
that that that racks like really kind of
rattles in you so I want to hear what
you think
well I mean honestly it's never been too
much of a tension for me
as far I've never I've never tried I've
never thought that I needed to write
songs or lyrics that
um directly correspond to sort of
My Life as a as a Christian as a priest
or anything like that
um all of my life in the church My Life
as a priest it all has tremendous uh
impact on how I write songs
um in the sense of
you know it's flavored with these ideas
of the Risen The rhythms of liturgical
life and all and the imagery of that and
the questions that I asked but
um it's just I've never felt compelled
to to turn that into something that's
sort of explicit
um
so I guess there's not a lot of maybe
the I don't know maybe the uh in fact I
probably try to avoid it more than
anything more than anything
um I think you know recently I wrote a
song over the last couple years that
actually has the name Jesus in it
um which is the first time I've ever
done that
um but it's somebody had written it in
graffiti on a wall right that's sort of
the that's how I brought it into into
that
um
and that's that seems natural to me as
opposed to
the pro you know the private thing that
we do as Christians
um
you know the privacy of worship and all
that kind of thing yeah I wouldn't use
that in rock music well that's a this is
why it's so fascinating in some ways
because
you have a sense of what is truly sacred
and holy and highest you could say
it almost does the opposite as what like
I said a kind of Evangelical would do
because the kind of Evangelical thinking
would be like yeah put Jesus in there as
much as possible it's like just throw
them in and so in some sense it's it's
particular because
you recognize the value or the a certain
hierarchy where it's like I I know what
I'm doing is not in the same space as
when you know I'm consecrating
the Eucharist right it's just not at the
same space and so I don't want to
confuse that hierarchy by by let's say
almost saying like you said if I it's
almost I feel in what you're saying it's
like if I
brought Jesus into my songs all the time
it would come and almost be like
blasphemy like maybe not blasphemy but
it would be like like a demeaning to
what the highest part of that is it's
our songs are not Sacred Space yeah to
do something to bring something into
that like and I've said this before in
other places but I don't typically talk
about things that I really love
I keep I keep those things for myself
they're private you know the things
musically the things I really love I
don't want to talk to other fans of the
bands that I like because you can't
possibly love them the way I do kind of
thing
um and so I think in some ways you know
I'm I'm terrible as far as being
Evangelical because I don't really want
to talk about price to people
um you know it sounds weird as a priest
to say that but like I don't you know I
want to
or even the theatokus like that you know
good example like I don't want to talk
about her to other people
um unless we share it in a communal kind
of space a Sacred Space the space of a
church or in that setting in a band it
seems like the worst possible idea
to bring that into that setting to me
anyway I'm sure you got comments
someone else on this question
I I it's funny because every time this
comes up
um
I think I'm becoming more convinced like
I have answers and I'm like I don't have
any clue how to answer the question or
how to untie the knot it's
and that kind of occurred to me more
recently how do you even answer this
it's you know I almost wonder what the
question is anymore what do we you know
what do we do with it I
I mean I got guitars on the wall and I
still I'm like I'm in my classic so it's
sort of like like Father Chris said
there's that tension
um maybe
maybe in some ways as a priest the rock
and roll part of our life is like dinner
on the dining room table versus
you know offering and this may not be
the best way to put it but offering the
Eucharist on the holy table you know the
two are connected
um who is it though I think it's father
Thomas hopco would talk about the
connection between
you know the fellowship meal you share a
coffee hour or the common meal after
liturgy versus the Eucharist they're not
opposed they're connected but there's
but there's a clear very clear
difference and um
the things that we might
um do and say around the meal that we
have at the common meal after liturgy
um hopefully we'll reflect what we've
done in the Eucharist and won't
contradict it but you know maybe we'll
you know we're not it won't be as
ritualized it won't be as
um it'll be sacred but sacred as an
informed sacred uh reshaped by the by
the by the true thing the real thing and
you know that meal that meal being an
image of the greater meal marriage being
an image of the true marriage you know
whatever it might be in rock and roll is
an uneasy
it's an uneasy fit and yeah it's like
there's this compulsion you know when
you've you've done it for all these
years you know to keep I mean I'm
surrounded by it here I when I went to
Seminary it was funny like the first
time I ever did this because I was much
worse about taking other people's gear
than I was giving it up but people left
it around there's like this rule that if
you leave your gear sitting for so many
minutes you know it's it's mine you know
uh people we used to have a uh in the
movie what what's that that's stealing
it's still yes but let's call it you
know let's let's gloss it here in the
movie we talked about the dish which was
this you know all ages club that we ran
that's a great story that I won't get
into but people would leave their gear
occasionally
and they wouldn't go back and get it
well it became ours when I went to
Seminary the first time in my life I
gave away here like I'm like I'm not
gonna need this anymore I'm gonna you
know I'm going to Seminary I'm gonna be
a priest I saw some regrets about that
because I thought you know that now now
I probably owe more gear than I've ever
owned in my life you know as a priest
you know you give up these things you
think it's going to become less a part
of you but yet you're you know still a
part of who you are but
I think for myself I'm more concerned
that you know will the the stuff or the
music somehow
misshaped the priesthood you know that's
my primary concern like I'll be a priest
and I'll be a priest who picks up a
guitar and you know where's my street
clothes to play a show once in a blue
moon maybe but if that if that harms any
of this stuff in any way then I I need
to put that away so there's that that
tension of like you know is it crossing
a line is it doing something else but um
but like well like I said I'm not I
don't even know if that's an answer I
guess for myself I just keep making
music and that's the best I can do at
this point hmm
so maybe that's the next question in
terms of we won't name any names but I
mean has that happened have you felt
like
you've received criticism or that people
have questioned
you know the the your your priesthood or
question the the fact that your pastors
of churches because of this
I'll say first since I brought it up
I've not had that actually I've been
I kind of feel like people should so you
know I mean I feel the same way you know
I mean I feel like I've when we when I
became a priest like immediately I let
people know because I because of the
internet I'm like what guys you're gonna
get to know me you're gonna go on
YouTube You're Gonna See videos here's
here's some of my past history don't be
shocked by this and my folks have always
been just like they think it's super
cool and I'm kind of like maybe you
shouldn't I don't know I you know maybe
it's not bad I don't know you get put
into a category you become the cool
priest yeah you know yeah
it feels equally as uncomfortable
totally totally well it's funny I mean
my funny story about this is you know
the movie was hitting all of these Art
House cinemas around the country so it
was coming to the local
Cinema here
and I was just nervous to talk about it
to my parishioners I mean people know
about the band and all of that finally
somebody pulled me aside and said father
you need to announce that this is coming
because I think people would be
disappointed if if they know that it
came and and you didn't tell anybody
so the very first time I've ever
mentioned the band like from the ambo or
whatever it was like announcements after
liturgy and I just said well some of you
know that I'm in this band and everybody
just started laughing because like
everybody knows that but I've never
acknowledged it like publicly I said
well this movie's coming some of you
might be interested and I don't know the
place was sold out and most of the
people that were there were my
parishioners yeah you know so the Q a
afterwards it was just weird it just
felt so awkward but
it just it's somehow integrating at the
same time
so maybe maybe Father David this is a
question for you in in some ways I mean
maybe for all all of you uh because in
some ways I can see like the trying to
figure out how it connects hoping maybe
they connect somehow but have you seen a
difference in for example the themes
either musically or in terms of lyrics
that as you've matured in your own
lives in your own spiritual lives and
your own priesthood have you noticed
that there has been a change in the type
of themes that you're addressing or or
even just the depth of
of what you feel like you're able to
touch in terms of of themes
yeah well I mean definitely things have
changed
um but like I have a
right now I'm working on a just a very
short little EP that I hope to release
before the end of the year
um it's just home recordings and Father
James and father Chris are going to help
me with it but like one of the titles of
one of the songs is my eyes are up here
um which is typically referring to you
know women with her features and you're
looking at her features have been
through her face so I love that phrase
and and I'm using I'm converting that
into a more something to do with like
spiritual versus carnal kind of kind of
language I'm using it in a different way
so in that sense yeah like I'm still I
like to use provocative themes and ideas
even language
um but I'm I think I've all you know
pretty much for the entirety the band
almost you know I've been living at an
orthodox lifestyle so like I've always
sort of tackled some of these themes in
an orthodox with an orthodox sort of
mindset so as as I've gotten to be you
know been a priest last you know 10
years now
there are definitely things certain
things I won't say because it's just
it's too far it push it goes beyond the
uh you know the um Beyond The Pale sort
of thing
um but I still like to push and provoke
so
um
but yeah what do you hope that what do
you hope that does like what is that
that's messing with people I mean just
you know
I don't know I don't
like I my my
interaction with music is all about it's
very it's just personal it's like
thank you
first I don't and I said this a movie I
don't believe anybody who really likes
the music that we do even if they tell
me they do like I don't really believe
that first of all and I don't care
ultimately I I it's really about the
formation the creation of something that
that wasn't there that that is now there
which is why once it's done and it goes
out into the world I don't pay any
attention to it you know try not to re
reviews I don't really care about
playing live and all that kind of thing
I just I really like about the creation
of it and so
um
that's where all my attention is and if
I have any tension it's during that
process of saying well can I say this is
this too far is this too complicated one
of my solo records I use the you know I
use the f word at one of my solo records
a number of years ago and it was it kind
of but it's very appropriate the usage
of it you know and and it's it's uh I
like to use language in that way
um as a provocative kind of thing or
these imagery images that are
provocative
um
I don't know what the end I don't the
end goal is with that I mean I really
don't know it's just it's what you do
it's rock and roll right so yeah yeah uh
so that I think that the way that I the
way that I've been seeing it or trying
to kind of understand what what rock and
roll could be
because obviously it does
from the very beginning right it's very
associated with sensuality also emotion
and anger you know all these things kind
of coming together so it is a it's a
passionate thing it's a very passionate
thing and and so I was trying for a
while to think about what like in terms
of thinking of the idea of Christ
feeling all things you know the idea of
Christ kind of participating and all
like what role could it be and I had
this image of of Saint John The
Foreigner like that's the image I had
like there's something about being in
the desert you know like I I can imagine
Saint John The Foreigner in like uh like
a heavy metal band
right he's like he's out in the desert
he's like screaming he's telling people
to repent it's like it's more of that
kind of get with it folks you know
aren't why why aren't you seeing this
like are you uh
like it's not that that's not actually
the the executive space of your band but
this is like the image that I had that I
thought like in terms of thinking of
this idea of art of the north X or art
of the of them
out of the desert something like that
something about that um
anyway so that was the only that was the
thing that I could that I could kind of
see in my in my mind and the Aesthetics
of rock and roll seem to fit even with
that to a certain extent
I think for me as The Lyricist like I I
have always used
um the method of asking the question as
my primary
um way of writing and maybe that's the
way that the prophets would do it it
wasn't it was more of like look at what
you're doing you know look at this
reality and it's not that now try not to
give the answer so much and they talk
about that in a movie a little bit like
I'm not trying to hit people over the
head with answers but it's just more of
a look at what's going on look at this
reality look at what's happening
um and then
beyond that the church has the answers
that people want to come into the and
find the answers this is where you find
it maybe our role you know as musicians
is to ask the questions and maybe I
think that's a great I think it's a
great formulation you know and it's a it
is in some ways a formulation of
it's like you could say something like
as we as we stand in chaos it's there we
stand outside we stand outside of the
church then what is the for what is that
what does that mean and that's it it's
the question like it's like what about
this Lord like what about this you know
that's that that's the role of of the
outside to a certain extent you know so
that's I think that you really you hit
that nail on the head there all music
all good music kind of does that right I
mean whether it's made by Christians or
not that's what you know protest music
was whether it involved a acoustic
guitar or not you know it's all about
asking a question look at what's going
on so
hmm
so who who are would you say are your
influences in terms of music and in
terms of of writing
brother okay
um
I don't like anybody I mean you know
there are like very few things uh I was
listening so again I'm working on this
new project that I really all I listen
to anymore these days really is just
meals from I don't know you know who
that is or not but he's just a composer
um all all uh instrumental music and I
find that the stuff that I'm writing is
just basically trying to duplicate what
he does
um with vocals um historically uh
obviously some of the Olympics are
pretty obvious I mean I was a I was a
huge Miss fan back in the day and I
think I think Morrissey lyrically was
the most most clever and most
interesting there's also a big house
Martins fan I think uh Paul Heaton and
his writing was very interesting outside
of music I always referenced T.S Eliot I
come back to him uh all the time quite
often
and he can't get far in this day and age
without referencing Radiohead in some
way
um either either somatically or
sonically I think the songwriting
especially is just super interesting
um those are some of my
you know lyrically and musically being
the songwriter that's where I'm kind of
coming from father Chris and Father
James have their other textures they add
to that but
what about you Father James father
Christopher
um I was
at one time I was really into YouTube I
think they're kind of boring now but I
loved them when I was in high school and
that was really
that got me into the the sound like the
sound of things the atmospheric quality
of things
but then my brother and father Chris got
to college and father Chris introduced
us to like the DC Punk scene so
Washington DC had this Punk scene and
and there was just this energy this
Vitality to that that was totally
different than a lot of the like I was I
was hugely into like the new wave
movement and the 80s I love that stuff
and you know synthesizer and stuff I
still love it I I write that kind of
stuff but um but the the punk scene
particularly things bands like fugazi or
I loved a band called shutter to think
they just were poetically bizarre and
they the the lyrics were were um
impressionistic and made very little
sense but it was just really really
beautiful in terms of the way the guy
wrote and it was very influential on me
in terms of guitar playing because the
guitar the early records it was really
scattered and kind of interesting but
then like the way the way the singer um
Craig sang and just bizarre lyrics were
were in a good way
um just kind of influenced kind of how I
thought about writing guitars because
you know my brother writes you know he's
he probably at the time we started I was
probably writing I was writing a lot I
guess I was writing a lot of them it was
a band we were but I was writing a lot
of the music still but then he learned
how to play the guitar and he plays
better than I do so he started writing
stuff but then he uses these weird
chords like a seventh what's a suspense
you know what's a C Major Seventh I
don't know what that is I play power
chords so I have to learn I I was
challenging kind of the way and I still
do I think
the melody you know not so that kind of
influenced how how I was doing it just
play my Chords it's not gonna happen I
mean it just won't work I can't do that
I'm not doing it Rebel so that's what I
did
what I do
yeah and as they said I mean I was very
influenced by kind of the underground
Punk scene of the 80s and early 90s and
uh I would say I was more influenced
kind of ideologically in some respects
of just kind of this do-it-yourself you
know we're gonna start our own band
start our own venue and then music was
all just a part of that using music as a
means for just making change
um so certainly fugazi and all of those
bands I think musically I just love the
the energy and the you know as a bass
player just the almost like jazz
influenced
um a little bit uh and then certainly I
got into jazz as well but uh yeah
Radiohead and certainly I loved you two
and I always loved Adam Clayton's uh
bass playing and um yeah
which is funny because we don't sound
anything like that I don't think yeah
yeah well I think I mean when I I listen
to your the early albums like I mean it
really did sound like like the 90s in
its own way I mean it had it had its own
sound but it still had that you could
you that Vibe I don't know allows to to
describe it so what about now because
you're working on an album Now what is
how do you feel that how that's going
how different is is it how similar is it
to what you've done before
that's your job brother
oh it's so hard it's so hard nowadays
um
like we you know we I wrote a bunch of
songs uh over the last few years
um and we've gotten together a number of
times to try to sort of work them out to
see how we how we would put them put
them together and it just it hasn't it
just didn't work repeatedly it just it
ended up sounding just not interesting
and so probably not bad but just not
interesting and so
um I kind of went back to the drawing
board and just took all the songs and
just redemoed them in in a totally
different fashion using a lot of
keyboards and our page eaters and things
like that
um and I said okay let's just try to
record them like let us do it this way
and it seems like it's kind of work a
lot better
um it's very much less Democratic less
banned like uh and father Chris will
tell you as he's recording his baseball
I'm standing over him going no no no
don't do it that way change that into
the drama the same way I was sitting
right in front of his Kick Drum and I'm
like no no that's a bad feel do it this
way you know not that I play problems or
anything like that benevolent dictator
yeah and then my brother putting down
guitars like yeah he'd spend 10 hours
working on something I don't like that
try something else so
um so you're the dictator of this
project right now
it's gonna be you know good or bad it's
going to be sort of my vision for things
and so we have a hierarchy within the
bands right
I think you know for me I'm just not
interested in repeating the stuff we've
done in the past and then
so I think the new stuff is it's weird
it's different from us in the sense of
there's a lot of Dancy stuff going on
which is you know not a Dancy band
um but there's some just it's just gonna
be different I think which again in
terms of songwriting that's what's
interesting to be just not repeating the
same thing so
hmm
all right so good I mean I was gonna say
like I was gonna I was gonna bring it to
to my to my last question which might be
in some ways hard
considering the discussion that we've
had already but so like I said there's I
know there's a lot of artists that watch
my content a lot of people who are many
of them are post-secular the best way to
explain it they they kind of come out
they're actually went very much into a
secular world into the secular art world
but then became disillusioned and now
you know our let's say Christian
adjacent or actually going to church or
a catechum in somewhere or whatever you
know people kind of floating around and
they everybody's trying to figure out
how to do this right how to how to live
the their lives for in a fulfilling way
especially because a lot of them are are
professional like they do it as a living
like how to live their artistic lives
and also you know move towards Christ uh
and so
do you have something to to advise these
people like is there something that what
would you say if someone like came to
you in your own parish and had those
questions you know
um can I can I jump in is that all right
yeah um
again I feel like I want to say this
quickly because I don't I don't have I
feel like I don't have the answer
anymore which is kind of good but I keep
thinking about before before I went to
Seminary I was a Furniture Builder and
um
and how much when I became Orthodox in
the midst of that like in that period of
my life
the furniture was still the furniture
but something had changed like I I was
realizing like how much that can become
you know I mean your Nikon Carver so you
understand an iconographer often knows
you know that should be an act filled
with prayer but suddenly whatever you're
going to do whether it's you know
building furniture for a living or or
making art which in my mind in a lot of
ways are
there there's a lot of connection there
um I mean it's it's something that has
to be filled with prayer I mean I don't
know how everything our whole life is
supposed to be filled with prayer if
you're an Orthodox Christian and you
want to do things
I feel like I'm kind of skirting the
question you you want things to be good
in terms of your output you're a
musician you're trying to square
um Orthodoxy in a sense with rock and
roll or whatever it might be I mean all
you can do is is offer it you know it's
either it's blessable or it isn't and
um
for myself it's always been we said
before it's been attention I didn't know
what to do with it uh I still kind of
don't know what to do with it except for
the fact that it's sort of like it's the
natural thing to do you know I I've I
admit I'm you know I will be probably a
musician who makes
on my own you know rather mediocre music
until I die it's a natural output of me
whether it's something that's totally
Eternal or not I don't know the best I
can do is say here it is and then offer
it in a sense with a prayer praying that
it's something that's that's worthy and
that God can somehow uh make use of it
um maybe I read a story maybe some of
you read the book scent of Holiness
um it just comes to my mind that in this
book
and that again I don't know how good or
bad this is but in this book it there's
a tale of a monk and I think it's I've
seen other places who comes in the
monastery and he's this goofy guy he
doesn't really have anything to offer
the monastery and another Monk sees him
one night doing like gymnastic tricks in
the church and at the end of it he's he
falls down before the icon of Christ and
he just says I'm sorry Christ this is
all I got I'm no good at anything else
but I was a clown before I became a monk
and this is what I've got to give you
and of course the other Monk Is
scandalized and as The Story Goes he
brings another monkey and they spy on
him doing these gymnastic tricks in the
church at night when no one's there and
they're there to basically kind of clamp
down on him except for the fact that the
end of this one particular evening he
falls in for the icon of Christ Christ
himself appears and wipes the sweat from
his brow and says you know thank you for
your offering and the other two monks
are Shattered by this like wow okay we
you know this is bizarre but this is
what Christ is has um chosen to do for
the us now whether this is true or not I
don't know but for me when I hear that
story I think okay well maybe that's it
right there maybe there's something to
be said for that
um does that help people I don't know
but I I mean for myself there's that
tension and maybe I'm just I'm a clown
you know I mean that's all I can do is
jump around I don't know again I don't
think I've got the answer but that's
what comes to me when we talk about
these things for what it's worth
is that too weird I mean I don't know
I've kind of come to the the same place
that you know I I don't know if if it's
something to figure out yeah
other than it just you know kind of
embrace the the tension of it and you're
you're wanting to bring your
Christ into every area of your of your
life and so you know we don't have the
this dichotomy or these little like
segregated parts of our life as Orthodox
Christians it's all one life
and so we just want to offer up all of
our life whether we're in church whether
we're at our job whether we're in the
recording studio
um it's kind of I I think it's Abba
Moses I can't remember which uh desert
father is but you know talks about stay
in your cell and it will teach you
everything and so I think kind of our
cell is just whatever we've been given
whatever our obedience is whether it's
our job it's our the talents we've been
given whether one is a priest icon
Carver
um you know and just I guess just seek
to bring
that presence of God into the midst of
everything that we that we do
I don't know
we we'd also you know we need to
remember that Christ is the perfect
example of all of this right
right so his ministry was three years
long but his whole life you know as a
carpenter
um was he like carving crosses and
giving them to people you know probably
not that would have been a weird time
but you know his his whole reality would
have been offered up to the father as a
prayer and he and because he's Christ he
does everything perfectly which means
it's perfectly humble right so when
people come to me and they say yeah I'm
thinking about doing this thing or
whatever I'm like great do it and do it
as well as you possibly can because when
you do that they get well be prideful
about it tell you what if it's actually
done well it'll be done in the image of
Christ and it'll be perfectly humble
it'll be a great offering
um and that's you know like Father Chris
said I don't think there's necessarily
it's not a problem like Christ doesn't
call us to be Bankers or artists or
lawyers or Housewives he calls bankers
and artists and lawyers and Housewives
to be disciples that's what he calls
um so whatever you do do it as well as
you possibly can it'll be a good icon
um and if it's bad art it probably stems
from Bad theology get your theology
corrected
I remember at one point um after
becoming Orthodox I've been Orthodox for
a couple of years and I was in a I've
been in a number of bands but I well a
couple of bands and the other band I was
in other than luxury which was a band
called they sing as a slew
um we were playing shows and we were
playing shows a lot of shows on Saturday
nights and I was I was feeling really
conflicted with this and and I so I
would go to Vespers and I would leave
there and we'd go drive you know not
terribly far away and play play a show
one night I was playing at some actually
nearby place so I was talking to the
priest after to our priest father Jacob
after service and I just said ah I'm
like you know I gotta go play the show
this is dingy little club and so I just
feel so weird about it coming to Vespers
and he said well
like my brother said he said
do good just do it well play well you
know offer it well and and that actually
really put my my mind at ease in fact we
played really well that night because I
went with sort of a a piece and I didn't
feel like I had to like make this an
orthodox event for the people I just
simply took what I had at Vespers went
picked up my guitar and played a show
and tried to offer it to the Lord and
that was that's what we did Holy Spirit
was really moving really
all right well Father David Father James
father Christopher thank you so much for
your time and uh definitely let me know
when the next album comes out I'll
really want to listen to it and
everybody I think is the documentary is
it streaming somewhere where can people
find the documentary yeah it's streaming
on uh
oh I don't know uh Apple TV on Amazon
Prime all right okay yeah a few other
places
all right it's called parallel loves
right yep everybody look look it up and
then on you can on Spotify check out
luxury I have them on my on my playlist
so thanks thanks for your time
absolutely thanks Jonathan appreciate it
oh